so David when you hear Howard talk about
your show in the glowing ways that he
does what goes through your mind [ __ ]
many viewers that
I know we'll tune in now and watch Seal
Team you know look at any time he needs
a Blackhawk or needs to be picked up and
he needs protection in a way that's very
secret we can handle that mission for
him
um but you know anyone that like to get
that kind of love and respect from
someone like Howard and yourself is is
greatly appreciated and again what we do
on the show is really for these great
veterans that sacrifice what they do in
order to keep our great country free are
we doing enough for these guys when they
get back from their missions are we
taking care of them enough no we're not
I mean you you talk to some of these
gold star families who've lost their
sons it's just in the Special Operations
Family itself is so particular in even
the past I don't know a few years the
suicide rate has just gone through the
roof man there's just not enough help
for these guys man and if if our show
can make a difference in helping them
pick up a phone or talk to a friend
checking in and saving them and after
heard stories of that they come back and
tell me that and that's that's my
biggest reward it really is but no we're
not doing enough no way David could you
see Howard playing a guest role on the
show maybe a seal from a different team
you know what if we went back like we're
gonna create these worlds let's say we
went back to Vietnam definitely maybe he
could be like that guy who wants to join
who's struggling with the mission wants
to go through buds like what's it like
to go through buds he could be that guy
that could that kid who could but like
you know the younger Howard he possibly
could do it yeah what about Ronnie Mund
no no straight out no Ronnie Ronnie does
not have a guest role no I don't think
he has his man I think Howard has the
sarcastic humor this the found
Foundation base of knowing it I mean
Ronnie maybe you know I'm not gonna say
no right off the Bad hardcore but yeah I
don't know I'd have to wait and see on
that one